so a few times in the past people have
made some jokes i've seen jokes on
twitter on facebook even in youtube
comments
people say you know why don't you do the
symbolism of rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer
there's somehow of a joking element to
that question but i thought that i would
dive into the symbolism
of rudolph because i think that in the
figure of rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
we do have
the an image of a birth of a
mythological figure
where it rudolph seems to more than the
marvel superheroes more than the star
wars
world seems to be playing a much more
mythological
function than all those other characters
and so we'll look at why that is
and why his story seems to fit
in order for rudolph to uh to enter into
a more participatory mode
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so kind of like the modern santa claus
is a rather modern
figure you know the figure of rudolph
the red nosed reindeer is even more
recent in fact we even know
who created rudolph his name is robert
louis may
and uh created in 1939 wrote a small
pamphlet which was published by
montgomery ward uh
department store and since then right
away
the figure of rudolph entered into the
common imagination
and it seems like rudolph has
become the closest thing to a kind of
mythic structure
that we have in the modern world let's
say i would say even more than star wars
even more than the marvel comics and i
will give you a few of the
elements which make us understand that
so that you can see
how why it is that rudolph seems to be
playing a kind of mythological
role let's say so one of the ways that
you can know that rudolph
is playing such a mythological form is
that most people don't know
who created him even though he does have
a definite author
we don't feel like rudolph has been
created by someone in particular
we just feel like he kind of rose up out
of
you know the folkloric ancient folklore
and just appeared as this figure which
completes the story of santa claus
and so that is something that is
important understanding
these why how a story becomes
mythological
it actually has to become more removed
from
its let's say more mundane
um it's more mundane
source you know one of the reasons why
the marvel comics
are also approach the mythological
structure
is because although they were created by
actual people because they end up
being handled by all these different
kinds of people
there's there's almost a kind of complex
system which sets itself up which weeds
out some elements of the story keep some
adds some and there's this
this selection process which creates a
figure that has
more let's say um more ontological force
and so in the case of rudolph it seems
like right away was there at the
beginning
but we just forgot who it is that
created him and rudolph
became a character on his own who who
just manifests the story of santa claus
so why is it that he's so powerful now
one of the reasons why rudolph is so
powerful
is because in the very structure of his
story he manifests
something about the relate the
relationship between the end and the
beginning
and so rudolph is in the story of christ
there's this image that christ
is the stone that was rejected by the
builder has become the angle stone or
the capstone
sometimes the better term to understand
it the keystone which holds the arch
together
uh that is that the baby the best way to
understand
what christ is so it's the stone that's
different from all the other stones
let's say you're building an arch you
have all these stones that are the same
and then at the end you need something
to hold the arch together
and then you see this one stone that is
different from all the others and that's
the last stone
that you put together which holds it all
together and so
in that sense uh christ
has that talks about that process
which is that something which is doesn't
seem to fit
through the whole process can at the end
appear to be
the very source of the of that process
and that's what we see in the story of
rudolph
now in the story of rudolph it fits our
modern way of thinking as well which is
the kind of
uh you know the underdog mentality which
i talked about a little bit
in my video about equality and sub and
inversion
you know it fits the notion of the uh
the
the underdog who's rejected that nobody
loves and then finally
becomes the hero but in this it's more
than just becomes the hero
although although the story of rudolph
does follow that that trope which you
see in every single movie which is that
someone is rejected at the beginning and
at the end everybody celebrates him
you know it's there's something a bit
deluded about that story but in the
story of rudolph
it's that he actually becomes the head
of the sleigh and so
structurally he goes from being uh
marginalized and rejected to becoming
exceptional at the at the edge of the
sleigh and so
it's not just that he he overcomes his
difficulties
and then becomes the hero it's that the
very thing that makes him
exceptional and makes them rejected is
the thing which
makes him ultimately come to the head
of the sleigh and lead the other
reindeer and so you have this
this relationship between the
transformation of the end
into the beginning but also what you
have is if you look at the
at santa's sleigh you if you kind of
understand it now
all of a sudden something like a
christmas tree you'll see by adding
rudolph
to the top of the sleigh you bring the
sleigh together into this point
and so think of the sleigh as the
christmas tree you have
rudolph at the top you have the shining
exceptional light you have the star you
have the angel which is at the top you
have the
the principality of the of the
of the the tree and so and then in the
tree i've talked about this in my video
of about trees in the tree you have all
these shining other shining lights
which are lesser than the top one which
are which shouldn't you know you
shouldn't have an ornament in your tree
which is attracting more attention than
the star the star should be
the top ornament should be the one that
kind of everything all leads to um
and so you have all these other lights
inside all these other smaller
principalities
and then finally you have the bottom of
the tree in which you have
the potentiality of the world which in
which you have
the wrapped gips that are hidden in
potentiality
and so when you put if you imagine the
slay of santa claus going up
you have the exact same structure all of
a sudden you have rudolph at the top
as the principality as as the the
exceptional
light at the top and then you have the
different
reindeer that are like stars that are
like
other principalities and then finally
you have this sleigh which
acts lit you know acts literally as a
bowl
and in that bowl now you have this big
sack full of gifts
that are hidden inside and you don't
know who it goes to and you don't know
what's inside
and so you have the very structure of
reality is represented
by the uh by the s
the structure of the sleigh
you know by the rate rudolph at the top
with all the reindeer and
santa claus at the bottom has the exact
same structure as the christmas tree
and the exact same structure as the
christmas story i've talked about this
how this image of the star above and
you know the lowly bowl at the bottom
with the
you know in the darkness is the
structure also of the nativity icon you
have the star above
you have all the the um the angels which
are singing
you have also the the shepherds
which are hearing and so you have kind
of this link between heaven and earth
and then you have in this dark cave in
the manger and the place where the
animals eat in the
very all these images of this dark
potentiality
is where you have the hidden
principalities the ones that aren't
manifest yet and you have
the one in the the story of christianity
you have that which will
which ultimately also go rise up to the
top but in the story of santa claus
that's not necessarily the idea it's
more this idea of this potentiality
potential treasures that are hidden in
darkness
um and so you can see that one so when
someone kind of came up with the idea of
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
it is an owned property you know it's uh
it's it's
it's actually not a mythic thing it's
it's owned by something called the what
is it the
the rudolph the red nose reindeer uh
corporation or something
and so it's owned by so the image of
rudolph is owned by the corporation but
we don't get the sense that that's it
and i don't think they can
actually control the image of rudolph
you know it
it has entered so much into our folklore
that they have to be careful not to
control it too much or else it's going
to backfire
against them and so it seems like like
the image of rudolph is probably there
to stay in the story of santa just
because
it actually takes up a space in the
story
that was missing something which was
kind of calling to be filled
and you know the fact that some guy came
up with it
almost doesn't matter uh what really
matters
is that it it ends up recreating the
right pattern
the pattern that we recognize the
pattern that is the same as the
christmas tree the same as
as nativity the nativity of christ
itself um
and so it's interesting to see it's
interesting to see that even despite the
fact that
the let's say we could we could surmise
that
the rise of santa claus and the rise of
figures like rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer
are in a way are there to to push aside
the more christian element of christmas
and to try to find secular alternatives
to christmas and we can
kind of see that as a frustrating thing
and a subversive
element in in christmas but we can also
do the do just as
these things are trying to push them
aside what we can do is actually show
how
even though they try to they end up
manifesting the same pattern as
the nativity and so in the very act of
trying to cast aside the nativity of
christ
they end up reaffirming it by
manifesting the same pattern and so as
christians
as people who want to celebrate
christian christmas i think the best way
to deal with these stories
is to integrate them and to try to show
how
they are just one more image of
this transformation which happened uh
2000 years ago
this child that was born in a manger
which
uh revealed to us the mysteries of the
universe
and helped and gave us a way to enter
into
this mystery of the incarnation showing
us
you know what the solstice ultimately
refers to
what these other even pagan images
ultimately refer to and so uh so i hope
that everybody i want to wish all of you
guys
and i'm doing this just for patrons so i
want to thank you
take the chance to thank you for your
support this year has been really crazy
for me as you know
but it has also been really wonderful to
watch
people kind of gather around this
channel on the facebook group
now we have eclipse channel all these
people kind of volunteering their time
writing great posts
on the facebook group it's just been
exciting to watch all of this happen
and so um your support is what has been
making it possible
you know i have i hire people to uh do
the uh
to put up my uh videos at podcast
i hire people to manage the website
i have also hired an assistant to help
me with carving to free myself from that
these days i haven't hired someone to
edit my videos so much
just because i've stopped making movie
videos but maybe
that might be coming to at some point
again as things continue to progress so
once again thank you for your support
and i wish you again a merry christmas
as we say in the orthodox church i'm
saying it early because i won't talk to
you guys before christmas
christ is born glorify him